[MUSIC PLAYING]
VINEET BHAN: So I
think first thing
that will be useful
for the audience would
be a quick round
of introductions
so they understand and
know what your roles are.
So Mark, if you could start
with your role and what do you
do at your company.
MARK ZUZARTE: My name's Mark.
I am involved with
information security
at Loblaw Companies Limited.
We're a company
based out of Canada.
We're involved with
one of the large--
or the leaders for pharmacy
and retail in Canada.
We have about 200,000 employees
across Canada, both full time
and part time.
My role is specifically around
assessing security solutions
that are going to be used
in our different platforms,
and how we address our very
specific threat landscape.
VINEET BHAN: Shahar.
SHAHAR BEN HADOR: Hello.
My name is Shahar.
I'm CIO for Exabeam.
Exabeam is making a
next-generation SIEM,
making our advanced
analytics technology
available for companies to
get more out of their SIEM
And I've been with Exabeam
for about a year as CIO.
Previously, I've
been with Imperva,
heading both infrastructure
and CISO for Imperva.
And at Exabeam, I wear two hats.
I'm CIO, leading the IT
and the InfoSec operations,
as well as in charge of building
a Cloud product in our Cloud
SIEM offering, which we
recently announced at the RSA.
JASON LAU: And hi, guys.
My name is Jason Lau.
I'm the Vice President
of Information Security
for CoreLogic.
CoreLogic is another
one of those companies
that you don't know, but you
really touch all the time.
If you guys have
done a mortgage loan,
you've probably-- on the back
end, that probably involved
CoreLogic anywhere from
10 to 20 different times,
from the credit check process,
to the home appraiser,
to the mortgage risk data that
we provide to the mortgage
lending companies.
So my job is to protect data.
We've been very
aggressive in moving
all of our applications,
sensitive data or otherwise,
to Google Cloud.
So my focus is really Cloud
security and Cloud automation.
DEREK CHAMORRO: My
name is Derek Chamorro.
I work for eBay, and most of
you probably know what eBay is.
We are not just a
large marketplace,
but we also have many other
brands that sit under eBay.
So we have StubHub and a bunch
of other classifieds groups
that help users around the
world find goods and services
in their local communities.
So my main
responsibility is helping
to plan and research and develop
what our next-gen services
platform looks like.
So whether it is an
extension of a hybrid Cloud
environment, where
we may have data that
exists in a public
Cloud environment,
or how we further enhance
our existing security
program to protect
against next-gen threats.
JOHN NJENGA: My
name is John Njenga,
and I work for the Home Depot.
I'm a staff security engineer.
And my role at the
company is focused
on looking for tools that
provide us with risk assessment
or enhances our
ability to do risk
assessment across
the enterprise,
both in the Cloud
space and on premise.
And with everything
shifting to Cloud uploads,
we are looking at
different tools.
We look at different
tools, validate
that they can provide the same
visibility that we require
so that we can provide our
leadership with the required
risk assessment profiling
for all of the workloads,
whether they are in
the Cloud or they
are on the on-premise space.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thank you, John.
I think one thing
that will be useful
for the audience
would be to understand
what kind of workloads
you're running on GCP
and how you use GCP.
So John, if you
start from your side.
Other way this time.
Anything that you can
share and that people
can relate to in the audience.
JOHN NJENGA: So we have
different workloads
that actually run.
Obviously we have different
business processes,
some that are customer-facing
workloads, some
that are used internally.
We run a hybrid Cloud
on-premise environment.
It's a large environment, so
we have different tool sets.
We have different requirements.
And sometimes with
what the Cloud provides
with autoscaling,
it's very obvious
that we also have to, from
a security perspective,
be able to assess
what's happening
within those environments
in the same way
we do it on the on-premise.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
DEREK CHAMORRO: I
can't really talk
about a lot of what we
run in Google Cloud,
and probably a lot of
people in the audience
can relate to that.
But what we are doing is--
what my responsibility
is planning
for how some of our brands are
planning what that looks like.
So a lot of it has
been, how do we
replicate what we currently
have on premise within a Cloud
environment?
So our approach
has been taking it
from the host or the
application to egress or if
not, in the reverse.
So part of what I'm actually
talking about tomorrow is,
in further detail,
is our test use case
of how we were able to test
Google's perimeter defense
mechanisms with Cloud Armor,
integrated with a partner
solution called Reblaze.
And that was like
pretty much our use case
for how we're able to protect,
or potentially protect,
our workloads in Google Cloud.
JASON LAU: So for
CoreLogic, we're
relatively new to Google Cloud.
We started about a year ago.
We are now at about maybe
750 projects and about 7,000
servers, I think, altogether.
It's been really
interesting, because I
think one of the things we
see from the security side
is that the amount of real
estate that we have to protect
is really expanding really fast.
We've got the
on-prem data centers,
we've got data centers for
mergers and acquisitions,
we had an existing
footprint of AWS--
we're moving those into GCP.
So there's a lot of
things in motion,
and so there's a lot of things
we have to keep our eyes on,
especially from the M&A side.
We'll acquire anywhere from
two to three companies a year.
And I think now it's
more common to acquire
companies that actually have
their own Cloud presence.
So for us, it's really about,
how can we unify and centralize
them?
And how quickly can we get them
out of their Cloud environment
into our managed
GCP environment?
VINEET BHAN: And Jason, just
to add on-- your G Suite.
I think you have a unique
use case on leveraging
pieces of G Suite.
So if you could share some
thoughts around G Suite,
as well.
How do you use it?
JASON LAU: Yeah, certainly.
So I think we, like
most companies,
started out with the Office 365.
As we moved closer
to GCP, we found
that we were just
getting better value out
of the G Suite product line.
But that came with
its own challenges.
I think that when we looked
at traditional content
filtering, that gave us this
very binary approach to,
you can allow traffic or
you can block traffic.
And we needed to bring
in partners and solutions
like Netskope CASB
to really open up
those connections
to say, well, we
want to do more finesse things.
Like maybe we want to have
our users access our G Suite
instance, but not let them
access their personal G Suite
instance.
Or we want to pop open a session
and really see what people
are putting into S3 buckets.
And so without more modern
solutions like Netskope,
we really didn't have the
ability to address things
from that granularity.
So today, we're
not only thinking
about what they're
accessing, but we're also
thinking about the activities
that they're doing.
And it gives us the ability
to have more finesse rules,
like allow people to download
from different environments,
but we're more focused about
preventing what they upload
to non-sanctioned environments.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thank you.
And Shahar, you have a
unique role and position
of a security company
running a SaaS service
on GCP, where your
reputation and protecting
that SaaS service is
critical to the business.
So in that role,
share a little bit
about what you're running on GCP
and what was the key challenges
that you have seen.
SHAHAR BEN HADOR:
Yeah, absolutely.
So when we came to
design our SaaS offering,
and we were looking at
what's most important to us,
and obviously, security--
a lot of companies say that
security is a top priority,
but it's really not.
And I feel that we
really try to do it.
They expect me to put
it at the top of mine,
because this is what we do.
We're a security
software company,
and if our customers
cannot trust us,
then we would not have business.
And so that's why we put
it as a top priority.
And as we design the product
and keep on making progress,
this is something that
we always take care of.
And even if it
sometimes slow us down--
and I think that
most people here
would recognize that
sometimes it's, you
have to slow down to
get this done right.
So this is what
we're trying to do,
and we feel that the
Google Cloud provide us
with a good platform to do that.
And maybe one more comment
about partners' offerings.
I feel that three years
ago, this wasn't the case.
You would sit in such a
session, and there are maybe
a few names on the slide
show, and not all of them
have good solutions.
And that has changed.
I think that for those of you
who are considering a move,
the tools are there--
connect with your vendors and
ask them what's available.
And you might be surprised
that most of them
do have now tools that will
work in these environments.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
MARK ZUZARTE: Not really
sure I can follow that up,
but someone like Derek can't
speak to specifically what
we have in GCP, but I
can say Loblaw is a--
we're a hybrid and
polycom environment.
We have a collective
in Clouds, and we're
using a hybrid of on-prem
and in Cloud infrastructure.
We're looking to migrate many of
our on-prem apps, or our legacy
apps, to the Cloud.
We're also looking
for Cloud for some
of our web-facing
applications that we
use for customer-facing, as well
as some of our data analytics
platforms.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
And Mark, starting with
you for the next round.
When you were designing
the security architecture
for Google Cloud, how did you
think about partner solutions--
what roles they would play?
Any partners you want to
mention that played a key role?
And for the benefit of the
audience, what function
did they perform?
And when folks are thinking
about building a security
architecture, which are the
different pieces they should
be thinking about?
MARK ZUZARTE: Yeah, for sure.
So going back to your first
slide that some of you may
have seen.
It was-- you have to take
it a couple of steps back.
Google has a responsibility
for the Cloud,
but that isn't to be--
you shouldn't confuse
that with, they're
responsible for everything.
And some people have looked
at Cloud as a mechanism
to defer all of the risk or
all of your security problems
to Google, and then you don't
have to worry about anything.
The customer is
responsible for security
for what you put in the Cloud.
So your workloads, your
data, your source codes--
you have to make sure
that you implement
solutions or architecture
solution to address that.
That starts with building
your threat model
and understanding what
specific threats are actually--
can potentially exist
with that migration.
So some of the steps are--
some of the things that we've
looked at is network traffic,
and looking at a next-generation
firewall for insight
into what traffic is
actually happening
and what's going on
on your Cloud project
is very important.
Also, with many companies
being fairly immature
in understanding how
the Cloud is configured,
and what you can
potentially do, looking
at solutions that monitor
the configuration and all
the different switches that
you can potentially configure
is very important as well.
And then finally, with
many organizations
looking to move to
containerized applications,
and moving off of
traditional infrastructure,
you want to make sure that
those containers are actually
being secured.
And then you're doing
everything that you can
and leveraging the learnings
of some of your partners
to make sure that you're doing
the right thing for security
for those migrations.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thank you.
And Shahar, from your
perspective-- and feel
free to share as much detail
you feel comfortable sharing.
From a security
company perspective,
you have seen all the products.
You know all the players.
When you had to
design your security,
what were the different
components and pieces
you were thinking about?
How did partner products
help you provide
that comprehensive answer?
SHAHAR BEN HADOR: Yeah, so
Mark here talked about a few.
But I want to take a
slightly different angle.
I think that when you
start, especially when you
are new to Cloud
environment, you
need to look at what
is your hygiene.
What's your IT hygiene?
What's your environment hygiene
where you store your stuff?
Because you can buy
all these products,
but if there is passwords
to the exterior desktop,
then no product in
the world is going
to help you overcome that.
So I think that one
of our first priority
was to have our environment
clean and hygiene
and everything get
automated through.
We use some partner
products like HashiCorp--
a good product for Cloud, as
well as we use a Cloud WAF
and DDos mitigation service.
And because these are things
we felt that we would be
able to leverage apart there--
but for those who are just
starting their journey,
I think a number-one
priority should
be get your environment clean.
And then use the
partner products
to cover other aspects that
that hygiene doesn't solve.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Jason.
JASON LAU: So I think there's
really two components when we
think about partner products.
There's the product, but then
there's the partner side of it
as well.
And I feel like yes,
they have good solutions.
But I think that there's a lot
to be leveraged from working
with good partners as well.
I think five years
ago, I was more
the security guy that would
go work with a partner
and say, here's a blueprint.
Build this exact thing for me.
And now, I think I'm more
of the security professional
that says, here's some problems
that I'm trying to solve.
Can you help me with it?
And I think-- so yes, we're
looking at the solution,
but I think as we
look at the partners,
we're looking for their
expertise in the space,
especially what is their
expertise with Google Cloud?
Is it something that
they support ancillary?
Maybe they mostly support
AWS and they have a "me too"
approach to Google Cloud?
Or are they truly
a Google partner,
and they've really thought
through their approach
of implementing their
solution in Google Cloud.
But to me, it's twofold value.
It's ideally, yes, we
want a good solution.
But we really want
a good partner
who can understand our
context, who can grow with us,
and we can leverage a
lot of the expertise
that they've built
up over the years.
DEREK CHAMORRO: So
for me specifically,
it was feature parity.
And I don't necessarily
mean feature parity
from the perspective
of like hey,
we're looking for exactly
what we run on prem.
But also looking at potentially
deficiencies that you have.
If you have this exercise
where you can actually
build something from scratch
and build something new,
then what you're looking for
is-- potentially looking for,
maybe there's something
you didn't look at.
Or maybe there is a new
feature that is now available
that your partner
might be dealing with.
And so then you go through that
build versus buy mentality.
Well, of course we
could all probably
build it and spend the
cycle actually doing that.
But if somebody is out
there doing it better,
and doing it well, and has a
bit of maturity and longevity
in the service that
they built, then you've
been able to instill a bit
of confidence in that vendor
and be able to realize that
you can partner with them
and see how you can work
together to build the service,
build this product.
So what I'd say is, don't be
afraid of finding things that
might be not running
properly, or might not
be working properly.
But if anything, you
might be able to find
that in the partner that
you partner up with.
VINEET BHAN: And Derek, just
double-clicking on the thoughts
that you mentioned about using
Cloud Armor-- how to think
about application security.
If you could sharing
your thoughts.
You have done a lot of
groundbreaking work there.
DEREK CHAMORRO: Yeah, so--
VINEET BHAN: How
should companies
think about application
security generally?
DEREK CHAMORRO: Yeah.
So we deal with a lot of
bots, and bots both being good
and both being bad.
And so we were looking
at ways of being
able to have this portability
aspect of being able to deploy
something no matter where.
At the same time, also
understanding that potentially,
there were some things that we
might not have been catching.
So being able to take
advantage of a lot
of the behavioral aspects of
traffic that a lot of companies
are looking into the space, and
then partnering up with Reblaze
and seeing how they've
been able to kind of excel
at a lot of the visibility
that we might not
have been able to see, is
something that we found pretty
intriguing, and led us to go
through this test scenario.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thank you.
JOHN NJENGA: Just to
follow up with the comments
from my panelists.
There are-- when you look at
especially hybrid environments
where you're going
from traditionally
on-premise environments and
trying to secure workloads
in the Cloud space,
most of the time,
we tend to approach them with a
mentality of what we knew about
in the on-premise space.
However, because
the infrastructure
and the visibility
doesn't always
exist in the same way
in the Cloud space,
you have to be very
focused on at least working
with vendor products
that provide
you some sense of visibility
for the different workloads
that you have.
If you are primarily,
say, Compute Engine heavy,
then you want to
look at products
that give you visibility
from both the network layers
and then from the
Compute Engine,
and how the Cloud as a space,
and all the services that
are running in it,
are interconnected.
Because that's the only way
you have a really good way
of trying to make sure
that your policies,
your baseline policies
from a CaaS perspective,
from a DLP perspective, from
a vulnerability management
perspective are
covered by the tools
that you decide to put in place.
And we work with
different vendor products.
Some of them were actually
listed on the slide previously.
Qualys is one of them
plus a couple others.
We are also looking
at the ability
to have visibility
across the Cloud space
to see all of the
services, connectivity,
and how that is laid out.
Then create and come up
with strategies around
security in all of the--
in the Cloud space.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
And Mark.
MARK ZUZARTE: Yeah.
I think I'll add just
one comment back to that.
Listening to all
the responses, is
that if you're
migrating to the Cloud,
you might not have an
app that's perfect,
or you might not have a
workload that's really secure--
really clean.
You have to think about how
the risk and the threats
are changing from moving from
an on-premise environment
into the Cloud.
And this also gives you
the unique opportunity
to look at what's working
and what's not working.
If you're using a partner
solution right now that maybe
isn't going to
migrate to the Cloud
that well, you have
the opportunity to say,
well, maybe this isn't
going to work out for me,
and I need to change that.
And that's one of the--
I'd say the journeys
that we had at Loblaw
is, we had a few partners that
maybe just didn't work out
so well in the Cloud, and we had
to say, well, we have to pivot.
We have to make sure that we're
going to be 100% successful.
And having that loyalty to
one specific partner maybe
isn't the right thing to do.
SHAHAR BEN HADOR:
Mark, there are
a few people in the
audience who are
working for security vendors.
What are you expecting
your security vendors
to do in order for
these companies
to be successful
with you, and have
a true partnership with you?
MARK ZUZARTE: That's a
really tough question, and--
[LAUGHTER]
So specifically about
being Cloud Native,
and really having that--
taking a number of
steps back and saying,
well, we have to do things
differently in the Cloud.
It's not about traditional
infrastructure anymore.
So what's different
in the Cloud,
how will you make sure
that what we're building
is going to take into the
principles that we're looking
to do, and the philosophy
of Cloud and DevOps,
and how are we
building it for that?
VINEET BHAN: And I think
this is a great question.
Anybody in the audience
wants to chime in
at what would be the
right security partner?
As folks are evaluating
different companies
they want to partner
with for security,
what are the key things that
you think are important,
in addition to what Mark said?
If you're thinking
about a partner,
what would be the
right characteristics
of that partner?
DEREK CHAMORRO: So a
lot of that, at least
for my perspective, is
just the portability.
So whether it's something
that you can run on prem
as well as running in Cloud,
and make it that very seamless.
If anything, I think that's
where some vendors might not
have focused on one area
as opposed to the other.
But it's that
portability factor that
makes it easy to be
able to transition.
We got really good at being
able to migrate workloads,
but if we're not able
to migrate an appliance
or migrate a product, then
we essentially pigeonholed
ourselves into back hauling
traffic back to a data center
in order to be able to have
that same level of protection.
VINEET BHAN: And I
think-- go ahead.
JASON LAU: Yeah.
So to echo on that,
I think we look
for partners who can help us
in multi-Cloud environments.
I think our desire and
intent is everything in GCP,
but our reality is
always going to be,
there's going to be some
laggard application that's
built specifically to AWS.
It's going to take us a
long time to get out of.
So we do need consistent
coverage across multiple Cloud
environments.
And then I think the other
thing is that today, when
we look at any solution, we
just won't take any solution
unless it has a
RESTful API interface.
Because if that vendor
cannot let us integrate
and orchestrate with
other solutions,
we're not even interested
in looking at that solution
at that point.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Thank you.
Any other comments on this?
JOHN NJENGA: To add on
to what he just stated--
especially when you have
multi-Cloud environments,
you want to have that
integration, especially
at the API level, so that
your provision of, say,
the reporting, or even
integration with existing
security tool sets,
be they on premise
or be they in the Cloud
space, is seamless
and appears the same.
Because when you have people
go into different tools,
then you end up with the same
traditional risks that we have
in on-premise environments--
multiple tool sets,
different datasets, and not
enough integration.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
So I think other thing
that will be useful
for the audience will
be to understand what
were the key lessons learned
as you went on your journey
to Google Cloud, or any other
public cloud in general.
And I was thinking more
in terms of not just
the technical lessons
learned, but organizationally
how security should
be done in the Cloud.
How organization
should be set up,
how the roles
should be defined--
if there are any key nuggets
that you guys want to share,
I think that will be
useful for the audience.
Mark, if we could
start with you.
MARK ZUZARTE: I think
what really helped us
out when we started our journey
was having a team that we
dedicated to Cloud migration
and adopting Cloud principles.
Forget about tech and
forget about partners
and the workloads.
The first thing you
need to consider
when you want to adopt
the Cloud is philosophy.
And what you-- really adopting
those Cloud principles,
adopting DevOps
principles, and making sure
everybody's on the
same page with what
you're looking to achieve
with going to the Cloud.
What are the actual benefits
that your organization
is going to be getting
from the Cloud,
and how are you going
to implement those?
So having that core team
that really were the bleeding
edge of understanding
what those principles were
was very advantageous
for making it successful
right off the bat.
SHAHAR BEN HADOR: And
to echo what Mark said,
I think that my learning is
that sure, a lot of things
are easier in Cloud, but
there are no shortcuts.
Like you have to have processes.
You have to have
planning in place,
and that is my key takeaway
from Cloud migration
and my first advice to people
who are starting their journey.
JASON LAU: Yeah, so when I first
wrote my first Cloud security
reference model, I
totally had it wrong.
So I basically had the
statement that said,
I want to make Cloud just
as secure as on prem.
And the fallacy was
in that statement,
was that I was
aiming for parity.
When really, if
we think about it,
we go to Cloud not
to co-locate, but we
go to Cloud to transform.
We transform our applications.
We move to
infrastructure as code--
blue-green environments.
We have to do the same thing
from a security perspective,
and we really have to
transform what we're doing.
But more importantly, I
think that we can never
set our goals too high from
a Cloud security perspective.
We always have to define,
what is my best-case scenario?
And even if you have
to temporarily take
reality and put it
to the side to say,
I want an environment
that is always
doing compliance auditing,
24 by 7 in real time.
I want scans to be happening
as things are spun up.
We have to hold
those as the ideals.
And I think that,
just as we're seeing
Cloud transform and
security transform,
I think what you're hearing
here is that I think as security
professionals, we're also
transforming our approach,
and we are moving more
towards automation,
more towards
bot-driven triggers.
Because we know that in
these Cloud environments,
they're so ephemeral
and they move so fast,
that's the only real way
we're going to keep up.
DEREK CHAMORRO:
So my takeaway is,
don't be afraid to break things.
What first start-- what
Mark alluded to was like,
don't be afraid
to break culture.
A lot of times,
it's the mentality
of that you can only do
things a certain way,
and by breaking that, you
can actually technically do
things a little better.
But don't be afraid to actually
break your environments.
We were in a fortune
situation where
we reach out to our customer
engineer and said, hey,
we want to DDoS Google.
And probably within
three seconds,
he said, yeah, let's do it.
That would be great.
He was really, really excited.
And when you realize
that you have partners
that want to see
you break things,
want to see these
kind of failures,
because that's
really what we learn.
These environments, as
ephemeral as they are,
they're a great
learning experience,
especially if you are first
migrating to a public cloud
for the first time.
But at the same
time, you're also
going to find
efficiencies possibly
in your automation process
or in your build process.
You will find failures
that you'll learn from,
and you will learn how to
make your environments more
resilient and better.
JOHN NJENGA: In our
environment, one
of the issues that we run
into is orchestration,
because we have
different business units,
and some of them have--
even though we are
the same company,
we have different approaches,
based on what business value
the team is adding,
and how they approach.
So there has to be--
In the Cloud space, there has
to be some kind of strategy
created, even for diversity
of different business teams,
so that you end up with the
same mindset in terms of how you
approach moving your workloads
into the Cloud space,
and also securing them.
Orchestration has
been a big deal.
Like Jason just stated,
having those tool
sets that allow you to
automate would actually
enhance your migration
in a very secure way,
and also be able
to monitor what's
happening from a security
perspective in that Cloud
space.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
So I think the last
question I wanted to cover
was more forward thinking.
So clouds are
evolving very quickly.
Security paradigms
are evolving quickly.
As security experts
in the field,
where do you see this headed
in six months or 12 months?
And with the goal of
folks who are building
their solution now, how
can they future-proof
what they are building?
So any thoughts you guys
want to share on that?
Containers or service measures,
or anything that you guys think
is where we are headed.
And what impact it
would have on security
and how that should be
baked into the design that's
being built today.
DEREK CHAMORRO: So just
from being from some partner
sessions and some
counsel sessions, I--
it's funny how we're changing
the way we monitor things,
and how we do--
previously we would
log something.
It would actually go
somewhere, and then we
would be analyzing
it post-event.
Now we're getting more into
streamline processing or inline
processing.
We're actually able to leverage
things like Cloud Functions,
or AWS Lambdas, or
whatever in order
to be able to do
processing in line,
we actually gather
more intelligence
before the event gets logged.
So we're actually-- our response
times are going to eventually
become a lot quicker.
And I think what
we're going to do
is we're going to get away
from the traditional aspects
of having these huge dashboards
where we're constantly looking
for something to happen,
and more or less become more
and more aware of what
actually happened,
and gather more
intelligence from that.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Anybody else from the panel?
SHAHAR BEN HADOR: I
can take this one too.
So I think that Cloud enables
all of us to move faster,
and that includes both the heavy
users and some panelists here,
as well as the vendor to evolve
their solutions over time.
So that's-- the next six
months are going to be always
exciting.
That's because everybody
can move faster.
So really looking forward to
see what the vendors introduced
into this space, and
what kind of new ideas
they bring to the market.
MARK ZUZARTE: So I think
the one thing I'll add--
and both of those are
both great points--
is security right now is--
even with moving to the Cloud,
there's still certain gates
that you look at.
You're going to do co-testing.
You're going to do a QA process.
With Cloud and doing
development in the Cloud moving
so fast now, it can't
be a gates anymore.
Security solutions just have
to be aligned and running along
with development and
workload development,
and putting up and
tearing down workloads.
So we just have to make sure
that as we build our security
solutions and as we
build our platforms,
that we make sure that
security is aligned
and moving alongside
with development.
VINEET BHAN: Perfect.
Jason.
JASON LAU: Yeah.
So architecturally, from
a security architecture
perspective, I always like to
think about things in layers.
And the solutions is never
the security program.
Our security program is never
a bucket of vendor solutions
that we buy.
It's really about
what our strategy is.
But then architecturally, at the
very bottom of that strategy,
are going to be core
things about how we do
security incident management.
Whether you in-house your SOC,
or whether you outsource it.
We outsource ours
to Secureworks,
because that gives us the
human analog and the runbook
processes.
Because every
solution that we buy
is going to generate an event,
and then we always have to say,
what are you going
to do with it?
So it's great to buy a lot
of things to generate events,
but if you don't have the
workforce to actually deal
with it, that's a problem.
So at the very
core foundation, we
focused on security incident
response with Secureworks.
We focused on security
orchestration with ServiceNow,
and then event
collection with Splunk.
And then every solution that we
built interplays with all three
of those at the bottom tier.
So it's really about, what is
the foundation architecturally
that you're going to
build that will eventually
support all the security
controls that you're
going to use.
[MUSIC PLAYING]